[Music]
trevor is with us trevor is in grand
rapids michigan hi trevor how are you
hi david kent how are you guys great man
how can we help
good
hey i have a career question um i guess
it's kind of a good problem to have i
think
a few weeks ago i was
in the interview process for
two different roles
and
kind of i guess company a we went
through the process
and they sent me an offer and so
i followed up with company b
and only to find out that the hiring
manager had resigned from his position
so
i'm a christian so i kind of saw that as
kind of one door closing another one
opening and i accepted the offer to the
first company um
well about a week later the leadership
from company b
um contacted me and asked if he could
send over an offer
so kind of the predicament i'm in now is
i have two offers but i've already
accepted
one offer from another company so
i'm just struggling ethically kind of
how to handle that situation
and so i just wanted to call you guys
for some reason on that sure so what's
the better offer for you clearly be
um
i think so yeah i think otherwise
there'd be no struggle yeah there's no
struggle so yeah right so here's what
you have to weigh um you're you're
morality you're a really good guy you're
a high character guy so you feel bad
about this because you want to take b
but you're worried about how they're
going to feel and maybe a little bit
more worried about how you're going to
look if you go back to a and go hey
listen i accepted the offer i was up for
two offers at the time here's what
happened
um and i think you have to say how would
you want someone to handle this
situation with you uh and so here let me
give you what i think is the the real
issue you have to get comfortable with
if you take a in other words if you stay
with a but you really want b and b is
the better offer
you're really doing a a disservice if
you stay anyway so what you think feels
like well i accepted the offer i've got
to be a good guy i've got to be high
character and i got to stay with a but
your eye is always on b i think it's do
it a disservice to company a anyway so i
think the way to handle this way i would
handle it is is to treat someone the way
i would want to be treated in this
situation which is be absolutely clear
and upfront about what happened the
timeline and everything they're not
going to be happy about it but you got
to do what you believe is right for you
long term what's the difference in the
offers
about fifteen thousand dollars a year
what about the companies
um
so one company uh company a is a little
more established um and has a little bit
more um structure so i kind of know what
i'm going to need to uh company b is a
little more
uh it's smaller and it's it's got
they're going through a lot of changes
there's a lot of opportunity a lot of
eyeballs on the roll they're also very
disorganized
hiring manager got quit or got fired and
they never followed up to you with you
until you'd already accepted another
offer
you're exactly right they had no handoff
they had no methodology for handing off
a lost employee and picking up their
workload they're disorganized
that's true
and so they're more of a startup and
they're flying by the sea of their pants
which one are you going to exist better
in i might be better than the startup
because i'm kind of that rough and
tumble guy but some people some people
prefer the structure and the
predictability
yeah and i'm coming from a larger kind
of publicly traded company so i'm i'm
used to that a little bit more so what's
what's most attractive about b is it
just the fifteen thousand dollar bump or
is there more to it than that
well that's that's certainly a part of
it um well is it the majority part
because i'm telling you uh for 15k i'm
not doing it yeah for 15k that'll wear
off pretty quickly
if you if you see this as an opportunity
i'm not as uh dave brings a very good
point but i'd want to know is this a
isolated situation or is this a pattern
across the board with how they handle
the miscommunication
you know what i'm saying
so a is it a pattern and b are you
mostly attracted to b just because of
the bump
it which i'm a pretty rough and tumble
ready to go with a startup but it would
concern me
if
that they dropped a ball and the ball by
the way was you
that would concern me yes yes as long as
it could be isolated i could see this
happening
so i want you i want to put you on the
spot you didn't answer it yet is it
mostly the pay or is this you feel like
this might be a good ladder for you to
climb
um
i you know i'm trying to reconcile that
right now as we talk um i think the pay
has something to do with it but i think
there's there's definitely opportunity
at both both places so as far as the
matter to climb like i think there's
opportunity at both places that's fair
what's the total pay
um
for the
well for which one uh the total i mean
either one 15 or minus 50.
so the the higher pay is 125.
okay so 125 or 110.
sure yeah so we're talking about a 15
swing give or take 14 swing yeah yeah so
um well i i would be perfectly fine
with either choice if i were you if you
want to walk into the other people and
go look here's what happened
i don't like this i don't even like how
it feels this is awkward i'm very sorry
i'm going the other direction and take b
okay um but i will throw into the mix
just as a part of the decision then i
don't think this is apples to apples
you're presenting this as apples to
apples plus or minus 15. and i think b
is a lot more unpredictable
and i i don't single events don't bother
me but if you can establish that this
this is a pattern
and this is the this organization just
simply does not run as well for whatever
reason and
that discounts it for me
okay and so i yeah
you you can decide that you can fresh
i'm sorry
okay i would say this is super fresh it
just happened kind of this morning and
so it's uh it's something that i that's
the type of stuff that i want to i
wanted to call you guys and like
think about things that i wasn't already
thinking how many employees is b
oh
200
and how old are they
five years old
okay same industry or different
industries
um
different industries all right that's
another question that i didn't bring up
i mean long term what do you want to do
for a living do you want to pivot to the
industry of of company b
well i mean i should i should preface
this i'm i'm in finance so this is like
a senior finance role so it's uh it'll
be financed in both in both
okay just a different same type of work
different industry
yeah same type of work but yeah i think
dave's really uh on to something here
fifteen thousand dollars is not a
decision that i would make for the short
term i would go long term
long what's the right long term decision
ten years now which one's gonna make you
the most happy that's finance you're a
very structured guy you're a methodical
process driven guy if there's chaos at
that other place it's going to drive you
nuts
you need to really know that before you
make this call
and um it's not worth the 15 bump if
it's going to drive you nuts
and then that takes the problem off the
table obviously i'm not sure that's the
case i'm just questioning how this whole
thing went down if that was the way you
ended up interacting with your
leadership team for the next five years
you you're gonna pull your hair out
that's right
yeah if it's uh if it's if if that's
what it is now we've got a little of
both around here honestly we've got some
areas of this company that are still
very raw very frontier very pioneering
very rough and tumble and very
disorganized and chaotic
and then we've got other areas of this
place that are running like a freaking
sewing machine there's the processes are
so dialed in and so professional and we
got 1200 team members so we got a little
of both going on around here so we could
get accused of either um it's not saying
that company's right or wrong i'm just
i'm just trying to make observations
about how this guy fits and where he
goes in the thing here so
um
yeah but but
uh uh
the way to handle it if you chose to do
b is simply just be up front and tell
the truth yeah all the way through do it
the way you'd want somebody to handle
you treat other people like you're gonna
be treated yeah solves all your business
ethics problems be classy here's why
dave this is relevant to this last call
shared an article today on the show uh
the ken coleman show 30 of people who
changed jobs in the last two years are
regretting it
30 they took the paycheck and then they
said it wasn't as good as we thought it
was going to be or i missed my old
company i miss them so you got to be
careful of making these kind of moves
just for a paypal it's got to be a long
term play yeah that'll be where you need
to be good point